we cannot begin with a few minutes offer
of you and then we're going to get into
an extension of where this goes because
we know roughly what these are roughly
very basic tests but we want to see what
we can stand you'll need your ruler
there if you have a template it will be
eaten all this so useful see this
morning I'm actually becoming a point
about that shortly but first let's
remember what we already know just the
basics about these guys and what they
look like
ok so you're gonna go through each
function inverse function it's the
native range and just the brief picture
ok the reason why we're gonna do this to
start with is because we're gonna look
at transformations this morning like
what happens when you move things around
you stretch them down and you turn them
backwards etc but obviously you've got
to know the basics really well the
fundamentals before me I can't walk to
the tender grounded move them etc ok so
come in where should we begin
suggestions ok let's carry the sine
inverse of X or inverse sine X if you
prefer so you remember to turn Y cosine
X into y cosine inverse of X we said
you'd better restrict the domain which
leads to a restriction on the range for
this guy right do you remember that so
we've got a domain and the range
what was the domain that we restricted
on the original function banks pursuits
play onto so that's going to become our
range restriction over here - pipe on
tuned for y because this is a range of
Shushan now again to pilot it takes the
domain restriction comes from what the
something that was innate to the
trigonometric functions before right
namely the airport so before the able to
was negative 1 to 1 so now that's our
domain restriction right so negative 1
to 1
happy touch ok
very simply therefore what does hell
graph look like and this one doesn't
have to be beat or beautiful we're just
trying to revise in our minds what this
looks like this is going to be an odd
function your or your domain and range
of the function itself everything is
nice and symmetrical so just like the
original sine function which in this
domain right was an increasing function
you remember the inverse of an
increasing function is also going to be
a decreasing function that's why we're
coming up from here to here do you
remember that now previously we had like
horizontal stationery points website
horizontal tangents if that's the only
kind of template there are but this time
art agents will be vertical right so if
you if I were you and I did not have a
template to draw this graphically I
would start by having my endpoints there
good morning
and during these vertical lines because
that will immediately stop you from
drawing the ends of these incorrectly so
they don't quite match the gradients to
get to once you've got those vertical
lines then you just want to draw nice
and slowly so you get a nice gradient
right there at the more acute okay so
I'm gonna try to do my best
I'm happy with that this is not meant to
be big or pristine beautiful but since
we have standard we might as well put on
or the domain and range for this so I'm
going from here to here that's negative
1 to 1 and here's my range which is the
opportunity to point if you want to be
really fancy do you make sure by the way
that these this graph actually ends at
negative 1 and 1 and actually gets there
so do include the of the food circles at
the end
the wave just stops and then nothing
happens right let's have a look at saga
doses brother there which is debated
range gonna be very very similar right
but slightly different so start with
domain what's the domain of inverse cos
it's the same rate because again this
restriction came from the amplitude
amplitude of the original trig functions
but we noticed because of the shift
that's different to inside and cause we
came up with a different rate
restriction for inverse cons do you
remember what it was we go from 0 all
the way up to Pike okay 0 up to PI so
again let's draw a picture and because
we've already got this rate efficient we
know which part of the graph we need to
draw we don't need all four quadrants on
this instance we're going to get
something like okay again my advice
start with your endpoints and draw your
your vertical sort of tangent T bits
first because that will help you get the
rest of the shape accurate I'm gonna
place one of the main points here points
okay one of the ways you could remember
if you do this in order you'll be able
to remember okay I've got an increasing
function for science I do this in the
same domain that I restricted before cuz
is starting from one and it comes down
to negative one so it's a decreasing
function in that domain which means that
its inverse is also going to be
decreasing right so it's one of the ways
you can remember which one is which I
need to put that midpoint in there by
the way what is that y intercept we
don't have winder
is it spy on suit okay so it does need
to be half way that's one of the things
that we'll be looking for for shape and
scale and once you've got that you've
got all the three points that are the
important ones you want a lot line up
through there are my vertical bits
there we go again we should put on our
many mores with these guys make sure to
point yeah okay
last one and I hoped it would be a
little bit audience think it right
underneath when we go for ten of us give
us domain and range okay the domain of
ten of us comes from the range of 10 how
far does 10 go up and down it goes all
the way right goes all the way we had
all wheel values of Y before so now
we've swapped everything around I'm
gonna have all real values on purpose
come in good money
oh you guys met the break Egyptian is
very similar to sign isn't with one
crucial difference what's the difference
yeah good I've got I've got asymptotes
here so I can't actually get to those
end points so it's exactly the same
without the boundary values I'm gonna go
from negative PI on to not inclusive to
play on to okay
I hope you've got a little more space
left on your page that I have on mine
we're gonna draw a set of axes here and
like we just pointed out we've got those
asymptotes than a horizontal now instead
of vertical okay there at negative prior
to implant those guys
okay now I'm going to have I mean if
when you think about the concavity
switching around it's going to be
horizontal over here it's gonna slice
through at the origin at what angle of
Miami for probably I want to go for that
45 degrees or I should say five four
right and I want to make sure it's nice
and symmetrical because of course the
original function tan X is an odd
function so therefore its inverse and
this restriction is also an odd function
okay now I'm almost done on this last
graph just not gonna be clear in here I
put on my label so I know exactly where
this thing exists I almost know exactly
where this thing exists almost I know
how far up and down it goes but at the
moment I can't tell whether this is tan
inverse of X or you know what it could
be tan inverse of 2x or tan inverse of
3x or tan inverse of x over a hundred
they all look like this so how will I be
able to tell which one it is I need a I
need a flip of scale right perfect
so what's a nice easy point for scale
for 10
why do you suggest yeah plan for now
pilot floor is actually useful because
I've already got plan two right there so
PI on four should be exactly halfway
does that make sense and again that's
something I should be able to measure
and then look at by eye we're really
good at hobby things right so if I call
that one pilot for that should be one
okay happy times I've done those are all
of the basics